the spare is going scorched Earth y'all
on the royal family and at the top of
his Hit List his big brother William as
Harry embarks on one head spinning media
blitz
I don't think that we can ever have
peace with my family unless the truth is
out there silence is betrayal if you're
invited to the coronation will you come
there's a lot that can happen between
now and then the board is in their Court
can you see a day when you would return
as a full-time member of the royal
family Harry's ready to blast the royal
family in four upcoming interviews
including one on The Late Show with
Stephen Colbert Tuesday night and yep
there's a lot to talk about the Guardian
newspaper is claiming that Harry writes
in his Memoir that William physically
attacked him during a 2019 argument
about Megan Harry reportedly claims in
spare out next Tuesday that William
called Megan difficult rude and abrasive
the fight escalated Harry allegedly
writes and William quote grabbed me by
the collar ripping my necklace and
knocked me to the floor Harry then
reportedly landed on a dog bowl which
shattered leaving him with scrapes and
bruises wouldn't your brother say to you
Harry how could you do this to me after
everything after everything we went
through wouldn't that be what you would
say you probably say all sorts of
different things you refer to your
brother as your beloved brother and arch
nemesis so the air was jealous of
despair
but that's just the beginning nicknames
are revealed Harold and Willie and
remember when Harry's Nazi uniform
Scandal made International headlines it
was really one of the biggest mistakes
of my life I learned from that
well Harry is now pointing fingers
writing that it was a toss-up between
two costumes a pilot or a Nazi Harry
claims William and Kate voted for the
Nazi uniform and when he tried it on
they both howled with laughter some
people will say you have railed against
invasions of your privacy all your life
but the accusation will be here are you
invading the privacy of your most
nearest and dearest without permission
that'll be the accusation that'll be the
accusation from the people that don't
understand or don't want to believe that
my family have been briefing the Press
another bombshell Harry reportedly
claims that his own dad King Charles
would cruelly joke about his paternity
asking who knows if I'm even your real
father according to the post Harry
writes he'd laugh and laugh though it
was a remarkably unfunny joke given the
rumors circulating just then that my
actual father was one of mummy's former
lovers major James Hewitt one cause of
this rumor was Major Hewitt's flaming
Ginger hair never mind that my mother
didn't meet major Hewitt until long
after I was born so what did the Royals
say we reached out and got no comment
maybe it's a difficult question to ask
or for you to answer I'm sure
GMA sit down with Harry Ayers Monday
morning 60 Minutes in ITV broadcast
their interviews Sunday night do you
still believe in the monarchy yes do you
believe you will play a part in its
future I don't know